in order to get motivated we focus more
on benefits close to the present moment
or away from husband very question I
think it's really important to imagine
your destination no way you're gonna go
what your moon mission is and and how
you can sort of get there working
backwards but literally you know with
any big journey it's the first day it's
the second step is the third step and
and you know and I know you can lose
confidence if you're not actually
delivery and you're not on track you
drift you're listening to all the cynics
they just kind of take take the oxygen
away from you so what's really important
is you kind of wake up in the morning
with a structure regime almost line will
all want to get out of it today what I
want to do for customers this week what
I want to do this month what I want to
do this quarter and you break it down
like that and it gives you massive
self-confidence massive believe you're
on the destination to be successful I'll
moon mission I like it this guy says a
lot of things that you gotta pick up I
like it i'm taking down so i'm gonna
rewatch this broadcast system anyway uh
like I entered that a little bit at the
top where I was talking with the big
wise and little wise you need both right
it's not only focused on the long
throwing only focus on the short term
got out both I think if you're to
long-term focus you'll lose motivation
short term and if you to short-term
focus then you're like why am I doing
this it doesn't have a bigger impact so
feeling out of a mix got a mix hey
inching just one think we're in Toronto
I know this guy's a massively Jays fan
oh geez I'm gonna went this so much that
we can learn from the order spool you
know the coach and you Vince Lombardi or
whoever it is in terms of having a big
plan you know winning the series but
that just doesn't happen by magic amp by
a lot of hard work a lot of training a
lot of discipline a lot of those videos
a lot of you know decomposing how every
minute of the game is played every
minute of the training routine and
connecting the two is absolutely vital
to success